we got the Aussie couch right here
because uh I'm with Max and Chad from
cold one how's it going hello
are you guys nervous all of a sudden
yeah cold one this is
you guys know how to podcast right it's
like almost like I have a podcast I
don't know how to do it sober
all right so this is actually uh part
one of the cold ones trash taste
collaboration yeah we have not had any
beers or alcohol yet but I'm sure on
your set we're going to be having plenty
I'll be having them on yourself oh
you've brought something I guess we're
starting can you grab some out of that
fridge
we're just getting started I can't do it
sober man I can't talk to a camera
so this is gonna be the more the less
strong version yeah oh wow what is this
oh wow
oh it's in you've got some you got some
Katakana yeah too yeah we had to put one
percent sochu in it just so we could put
the Japanese writing on it and it was
[__] expensive oh yeah these ones are
being changed
thank you very much
color it needs to be like yeah actually
vodka and soda oh you're great it's
grape and Peach we've got gravy but we
got this sounds like a dangerous
combination grape is getting changed
there but the peach is perfect I think
okay
okay yeah I guess uh cheers boys
come pie boys oh yeah I drank one this
morning
100 calories as well damn oh
that's good
I love by the way say that more say that
more yeah it's amazing Max and Chad I
love by the way you guys called it Grog
it just speaks for itself because uh was
there a reason why you put the catacon
on it you just wanted it to have like
Japanese
is this phonetically Grog like yeah yeah
there's no word that's or grog's barely
in English
exactly it's an Aussie English word yeah
do you guys use Grog in the UK not
written do you use it in Australia yeah
it means alcohol dude actually yeah I
think it was originally
what the poor people had to drink
um
like used for all alcohol yeah it's a
specific kind yeah we just got all
alcohol gross okay I thought I
understood Australia more than I did
today I went to go and get uh like a
plug adapter uh and then I went and I
was looking at the aisles and there was
a thing called Globes and I was like
well that's impressive they have a whole
aisle for Globes and so I go to this
island where the [__] are the Globes and
I realized they're talking about light
bulbs I've never heard that before I've
never heard yeah what someone calling a
light bulb a globe what I call them
gloves
yeah
and there was something better word okay
I don't know can you tell what this is
it said Manchester what was that
[Music]
yeah obviously I don't know because I'm
drinking too much of this [__] you've
had one [__] sip already but uh what
are you talking about oh my God before
we get into it we should probably uh
just in case if there's anyone in our
audience who don't know who you guys are
do you guys want to introduce yourselves
to our audience yep Chad go ahead
um uh drink alcohol
um do funny
let's put on camera yeah
edit
Ed
uh yeah you know we've got a channel and
I'm sure a lot of people who would kind
of watch this would know all of you if
they like YouTube because you guys have
been around for a very long time yeah
various stuffs on the internet yeah
uh my first video was
2007. damn I think your your original
um some of your original prank calls
were some videos I took inspiration from
when I did start I did prank calls when
I first really yeah but way more cringe
as it is anime characters
um yeah I think that's why I did pretty
bad to look back on I think if I was
doing practice Yeah just they just don't
she's like I'm harassing someone
is everything you do when you're younger
and you think is so funny and you age
out of it you're like wow she's a dick
yeah
it's okay you have your Arc right yeah I
was I wanted to if I was going to go
back to the main Channel I want to do
like a a thing where I would go to some
of those businesses that I completely
[__] with and maybe do like a full
video where okay hey I'm sorry for doing
like a Redemption I'm sorry for [__]
your company up
who are you
well there's there's one there's one
specifically I know I'd start with which
was uh Lord of the dings which was like
a car repair store yeah
it's like a very local like a local
store it was just some yeah usually I I
beeped the names out of the stores that
I'd call because I didn't want them to
get any [__] but yeah this video sort of
hinged on the fact that the name was
called that or something so I didn't
remove it and then people started oh
they got like a lot of harassment to the
point oh yeah it was on like the local
news and then the guy was just yeah he
was being interviewed by the news saying
like oh my my company's [__] like all
these [__] are calling me and
constantly I can't run my business Sam
Asal now his crash repair business lord
of the dings nine years ago for a laugh
you come down here I'll caught your head
with a rock mate Sam reported the calls
to police but was simply advised to
change his number
as well
okay so when is the Redemption
you go to the company you're just like
by the way you're anyway yeah I'd maybe
want to do something with him be like
hey sorry for that bro
after all those years here's some money
to change the name of the company
because I think he still has the same
name but obviously it's still doing well
he probably did my phone yeah yeah maybe
maybe I was too scared to call British
one so I just called American companies
because I thought what are they going to
do extradite me yeah like
yeah I mean like honestly I'm gonna ask
for a second because when we uh when we
had the idea to start a podcast for
ourselves we're like I don't know what
the [__] we're doing uh and we're gonna
be honest half of our like Direction was
just let's just look at cold ones and
just [__] copy what they're doing
didn't you send a clip in the chat
because obviously we're doing you guys
next so he was I don't research he does
the research yeah and Max like linked
the clip from the first episode it's you
saying that yeah we're just gonna drink
on this constantly
you're a YouTuber you're all YouTubers
and you don't constantly drink
cocaine addictions then okay
we would be imprisoned super fast in
Japan I mean not cocaine addictions not
even that I want to by the way I do not
want to but even if I did we would be
[__] yes one sec does anyone got a
tissue he's gonna hang Boogie it's piss
me off
he's got it don't worry
I would like one thank you
I'll take a tissue there you go speaking
about drinking is that is a huge part of
your brand
um you know as you get older you do
worry you're like man should I drink
less do you ever have a concern where
you're like man maybe we just [__]
drink way too much on this we
specifically May a lot actually happen
having that like uh battle like
realization because
I'm 28 now yep and it actually like I
don't I love drinking I still love
drinking I do too I love I mean we're
doing it now man I can't I can't like
express how much I love drinking but I
hate drinking and then having to like
worry about work because we we drink
yeah it comes like an end of recording
I'm worried I'm like oh the Disco right
oh is did I say this like I don't upset
this person because uh you know you
don't be addicted yeah yeah and like I'm
drunk but I'm trying to work at the same
time so I [__] it used to be a lot
easier because it'd just be three of us
it'd be like me Scott and Max yeah right
I'm filming these videos and now we've
got like a whole production team like
we've got editors we got like a [__]
writer and they're all there and it's
like I can't get drunk and then like try
call the shots because I'm [__] drunk
so yeah
um what about the health yeah I wonder
if there's like oh yeah any kind of
approach to it was it health is there
like a business you know is there a
thing of like hey we can't do this like
10 more years the whole thing I don't
really care
but but there is I definitely have had
the conversation myself like I think
there's some yeah we can't drink that
much this week because I like to feel
like [__] and we definitely die of the
back yeah we still drink a lot but like
when we started hmm it was like every
episode every episode was like a
blackout like oh yeah she didn't like it
now it's sort of just like good tips
which episodes are the ones that you
need to drink in
because sometimes the content is just
like not as engaging no because there's
there's stuff that the content is
turning children's toys into drinking
games
celebrity alcoholism yeah right trying
celebrity alcohol everything else that's
not that now we try to basically remove
it so you kind of just like sprinkle it
throughout the schedule all right yeah
yeah right so you're like we're getting
blackout drunk for this one this one
also we're just getting like I still
really like socially drinking I love
socially drinking right I was like I
don't want to suck and I can't do it
more than once a week because I'm older
for days like another thing is if I
drink on a Thursday I ride off my next
day so like same here that's that's when
I stopped having to like you know calm
down the drinking as well I remember so
vividly like when I was like in my early
20s or something I was like drinking my
cousin's like you're gonna know when
you're old when a hangover lasts more
than one day I'm just like I didn't know
that could happen that was [__] up
yeah that happened I was like yo bear
I'm never going to get old and I
remember I was like 26 or something and
I woke up the day afterwards I'm like
[__] oh [__] was right I'm getting old
and uh yeah it's like now you're now I'm
30 and I'm like [__] I can't if you're
30. I'm 32. you're fine
I'm so sorry
he looks the youngest out of all of us
though it's so far
photos of me from 10 years ago when I
still look the same it's [__] up I
don't feel like you don't no are the
beard did wonders for you though yeah
that covers up all the [__] Battle
Scars
wait how old are you Max
30 soon oh okay these are 32 though
that's crazy though because to think of
like like you mentioned like you started
doing YouTube in 2007 that's yeah
yeah okay that's very yeah we've known
each other for 11 years now did you guys
meet through YouTube
I follow him on Facebook when he used to
have a Facebook this before Twitter was
a thing I just I basically just had like
a a normal Facebook account yeah that I
was like everyone on my YouTube add me
on Facebook literally just that until it
reached like the cap I just commented on
this thing I was like you want some
Darboy gold and then sorry you were
saying that again I said you want some
Diablo gold what's oh yeah oh my God I
was brought to you I was right Diablo at
the time or something unrelated and then
yeah Chad commented on one of my
statuses or something like do you want
some gold yeah you're a big you're a
huge gamer right
yes
right right yeah like MMOs right yeah I
still play MMOs like it does nothing I'm
getting older I can't play games as good
as I used to the green is good I used to
be great at Lego queued up for a gamma
League the other day [__] I can't
play for [__]
I was like what happened to my brain oh
the alcohol the alcohol
we're gonna drink one before getting in
the queue so yeah and I I still play
like MMOs because it's more of like a a
social thing because like all my
guildies are all like Melbourne based
we're still like really good like
players and we're like we kill it every
weekend that's when like World of
Warcraft and stuff like sounds fun when
you like actually get like meaningful
kind of friendships and bonds from it oh
we we did like a guild meet up for Wrath
of Lich King launch and we're like this
that sounds like a hot tub and like
cocaine and like
yeah
this is a three-day binge of like
[__] playing like World of Warcraft
and uh that was good and they're like
some of my closest friends and there's
some people that I've known in my guild
for like 15 16 years even longer than
that yeah right yeah it's kind of um
okay so so you sent Max a message asking
if he wanted some gold yeah and then you
know we connect a lot through my teeth
and end up meeting him and uh they
didn't give us a goals
wait wait wait wait wait wait what did
you lie about I said yeah man I'm a
[__] yeah
I literally said that
to make himself seem interesting enough
for me to like care I think he was like
ah I just got done playing like league
in Japan or something or something like
that yeah I don't think Japan has pro
games you said some [__] about it you
literally toured around like or some
[__] because you played so well and
you're like almost but I was good at
League the one country on Earth they
don't give a [__] about me yeah and then
and then we met and then uh because I
came here because I had family that
lived in Perth and then I flew there and
then I went back home for a little bit
and like finished like school and [__]
like that and then
um moved back to Perth I kind of like
I I grew up in like a small town I
didn't want to be there anymore yeah so
I like just was speaking to Max still
and then I ended up flying back to Perth
and then well you're both from Perth
right no no I'm from Queensland oh
you're from Queens yeah yeah yeah and
then yeah we just kept in contact and
then yeah and then and then there's a
guinea pig well we needed we needed like
a meat Mogul we needed like a meat logo
a human experiment I needed someone for
the filthy Frank videos to you know
torture yeah
is there was that okay
how'd that come about that's where
Chad's name came from what do you think
yeah he's from a filthy Frank video yeah
yeah he was the character as hey this is
anything for views like he'll do [__]
anything was there any kind of
yeah I know a guy will probably do it
I know okay wait how did this
conversation come out was it like what
video were you making you're like I need
a guy to just do something [__] like
what was the first video do you remember
that you were in like the uh the first
video I did was
I don't think it was the I can't
remember I can't [__] remember hey
was it the PewDiePie tattoo can we get
that out I I think people like that was
like the first video where the name was
in but I was in some other videos of
yours right oh yeah that is where the
character came from yeah yeah yeah yeah
I couldn't tell you when the first video
was can we see the tattoo or oh I mean
can I show it yeah yeah go ahead there's
some more there that will like never
wrong by the way
oh my God
yeah I see I see I see it very clearly
very clearly Frank there one that never
got used
oh my God